all right so want to give you guys a
little look at the headset so obviously
we've got our little cover on here so
when we take it off we are greeted with
this beautiful front display now this is
a modular system so if we don't want to
have the solo knit Loop we can just pop
this right off we've got these little
pull tabs right here you just pull pop
them off and then we can just put on the
Dual Loop band so what's cool is if you
do want to give someone guest access and
they have a different size head you just
need to order the different size light
seal and the cushion and this will allow
you to just Swap this out to give
someone access to guest mode now this
device can only be registered to one
person so using optic ID this will
basically be sealed to you so you just
line up the little dots and then you
rotate so you'll see there's a little
light right there it's blinking and as
soon as it turns solid then the headset
is ready to be put on